I just love on statham says it it's a
Megalodon the may so the Meg is a
monster thriller involving a big shark
called a Megalodon thought to be long
extinct but down in the Laurentian abyss
we didn't know that there was more abyss
to the abyss and we've unleashed the
Megalodon and if it sounds like
sharknado with one shark that's a bigger
shark minus the NATO it's kind of is and
that's where this movie thrives this
movie is at its best when it commits to
its absurdity the movie knows what it is
and plays up what it is just owns it
that is invaluable and sometimes the Meg
does that but is capsizing boats awesome
and it's biting the glass leaving the
teeth marks awesome for the movies
all-around being destructive it's fun
however I will scold the marketing
department for that bait and switch
anything with that Beach that's the end
of the movie for the most part the
movies just trying to figure itself out
sometimes it's trying to go after the
shark other times it's a rescue mission
but for 90% of it is more akin to deep
blue sea in the sense that it's just in
this facility in the middle of the ocean
in the middle of nowhere only sharks
aren't invading the facility because
they're getting smart a cast for the
most parts pretty forgettable I mean
Jason Statham is awesome because he's
the man's man he's the kind of guy who
will dive headfirst into the ocean when
that big thing is circling the facility
or a boat or whatever because he stayed
them he makes [ __ ] happen I want to see
Statham with a shirt that says I make
[ __ ] happen it would only be to finish
he was great Rainn Wilson comes in as
this douchey billionaire he pretty much
owns the place and I pretty much I mean
he does so you got Rainn Wilson he's the
billionaire and a shark who's attacking
everything what character do you think
you would play pretty much plays that
for the most part I don't lie there are
some characters in here I even forgot
they were in the movies like all they're
dead oh that's right they were a thing
in fact I'm 5050 there are some
characters I don't even know if they
died in this movie that's how
forgettable they were is I didn't
remember whether or not the shark killed
them really the movie mainly falters
this is the biggest gripe I have about
the Meg is that sometimes it tries to be
more than it is sometimes it overreaches
it tries to elevate itself slightly too
much it tries to have some super
sentimental human moments of emotion and
for the Meg it doesn't really land
I'm not saying human moments are a bad
thing you should have human moments in a
movie like that but when you try to
overcook it really bring on the
waterworks in a movie like the Meg kind
of comes across as happy gilmore when he
couldn't accept the fact that he was a
golfer he's like no I'm a hockey player
that's
what I'm good at is like no you are a
golfer know that own that and commit to
that like sometimes a Meg wanted to be a
deeper movie than the mega actually
could be guys in the end the Meg had
some fun cheese in it about halfway
through the movie maybe two-thirds of
the way through the movie it's like
something happens and I was like oh this
movie picked up this movie committed and
from there to the end actually had a
really good time the first two-thirds of
the movie I felt we're a bit too long
and overblown you can still snicker and
laugh at the cheesy script and the lines
that people are delivering sure the
movie takes a bit to get going and start
showing what the audience came to see
which is funny to hear me say that when
I went into the movie with literally no
expectations the movies dumb not as fun
as it could be but it does have some
dumb fun and it might perfectly land for
you if you're a bit drunk ya know it's a
party alright so the meg have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know or
what's your favorite animal disaster
maybe shark movie you get what I'm
trying to say anyhow whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]